and now do you look at the new school of
skaters and are you just blown away by
i'm florida because i saw you working
with a kid that just busted out the 900
he was like how old like 10 or something
12.
it's like yeah young young guys can can
do the crazy tricks
yeah i think it's because well they have
the resources now but also
there's an element to when you're trying
to do something new if you know it's
possible if you know what's been done
it's way easier to get
there's a phenomenon i forget the name
of it what is it called it's like the
guy that ran the five minute four
minutes yeah
something like he actually it's it's i
mean not to get into the whole like
visualize thing but like literally his
strategy was i'm gonna visualize exactly
how i'm gonna do it and then it becomes
attainable and then he [ __ ] did it
but uh and then this happens throughout
history there's like one guy who ends up
doing it or girl who ends up doing the
thing and then all of a sudden it
doesn't seem like the most shocking
thing i think it happened four minute
miles like one person broke it yeah
immediately in the next year
so there there had been this this chase
or nine hundreds that happened over the
course of
almost 10 years and there were only a
handful of us that were even really
trying and getting close
and then after i made it
uh sandro diaz did one a month later in
brazil georgia tony did one in italy
like two months after that
it just started
it just started now
did you share with them what you learned
were you like hey you gotta lean back a
little bit and then no they both had
different techniques but they'd both
been trying it it was more that they saw
that it could be done did you visualize
did you were you doing any of this stuff
or were you just like yeah i'll just
keep trying
i was until i broke my rib okay i was i
was obsessed with that that's all i
would do go go skate to try that and
when i finally did
what i thought had all the elements to
it
and ended up falling and breaking my rib
maybe i can't do it
[Music]
so you almost thought it might not
happen
yeah i mean i kind of even even leading
up to the x games like kind of getting
up because i was just like i already
gave them my all [ __ ] get the prize
so that announcer yeah yeah dave duggan
yeah
[ __ ] duncan that's
there was this backyard skate event a
couple months ago
and christian soy was there
uh christian soy is a legendary skater
from the 80s okay he was basically my
rival in the 80s okay okay he
represented air and style and i
represented
tricks
and people had to choose sides
okay that was very much like the free
bread of our relationship yeah no i mean
we were friends but but in terms of fans
the pr and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah you
didn't you didn't
messy you did not like christmas and
tony hawk you had one or the other one
yeah
um but we were skating and they had a
legends division so christian and i are
skating in this legends division and
dave duncan is the announcer and he's
like
why don't we see some doubles from you
guys
both you know
we've never done doubles before yeah
that's right it was you and mcdonald was
andy mcdonald's
yeah you guys would do the devils yeah
but even just for a like for a video or
a photo or something and so he and i
just
whipped something up and ended up
getting a photo of it and now we're
selling that for charity you can get it
right now
where do they get it tonyhawk.com there
we go this guy is your guardian angel
dude
i just remember that like oh and it's
because he said yeah you guys should do
doubles and now it's like became a
fundraiser for the skateboard project
wow you gotta change the world was there
ever a time where like you when you
really started popping on like
mcdonald's and like the big brands are
coming like the fortune 500 was there
ever a time where the community
was uh felt like you were leaving them
uh no it was more not leaving them but
just more
there was a sellout yes absolutely yeah
now i think that the that started with
bagel bites i had a big promotion bagel
mites
in 1998
[Laughter]
yeah but that was that was the moment
when people thought
okay this is not skateboarding bagels
yeah like you're selling out and and
somehow they thought that i
i didn't have a value system and what
did they think sponsorship was
they're all sponsoring every procedure
everyone else it was it had to be
endemic
so it had to be escape branch
shoes thank you for defining yeah
you're way too smart
right
damnit i didn't understand
what what's going on yeah i don't want a
pandemic sponsorship i've got enough of
those um
and so when when i did a big promotion
it was like
it was like how could you
and he said well how could i i've been
skating and
professionally since i was 14
if if i had gotten the opportunity to do
that when i was 14 or 18 or when i had a
kid when i was 24 like sign me up yeah i
i eat bagel bites
i eat mcdonald's yeah you know i'm not
changing
how i view the world or my value system
for money it's just more like yeah now
and now i get to use their marketing
money to promote skateboarding that's
really how i saw it yeah and a lot of
people think that that's like a cop out
but that is absolutely the truth because
i had i had final control over how
skateboarding was presented in those
in those um advertisements oh really and
so
i knew that we're going to reach a new
audience
so you've always had this thing where
like you want to be an ambassador for
the sport i think that that's where it's
that's where it started interesting
because it was like oh this is you know
with great great power responsibility
but this is an opportunity to really
show skateboarding for what it is and
not just what they see
on x games or in needs yeah um and i got
to do that
again and again i got to do with bagel
bites and
mcdonald's and car manufacturers um and
and also
now i whenever i do any kind of
promotion like that there is a caveat
that they have to donate to
foundation skateboard projects so i'm
literally helping build they're helping
build more skateboards this is this is
interesting like
i think a lot of times it
when people
reach
you know high high levels of success and
uh there isn't this feeling that they're
like giving back to the thing that
helped them reach the success there is
some animosity from those who don't have
that success right and because it feels
like oh you're just using this thing so
you can extract as much resources as you
possibly can from the world and i think
it's it's i mean you're doing this
because it's genuine but i think those
people who feel like a responsibility to
continue like spread the game if it's
basketball [ __ ] soccer skateboarding
stand up whatever it is like if you feel
responsibility to like keep kind of
pushing it it's really hard to be
critical
it's like you use this thing to gain
wealth and now you're giving back to
this thing so other people can hopefully
use it to gain wealth
um
yeah and i guess it's more that i just
i've come so far in it yeah
and and i i hopefully have proved myself
to still be committed to skateboarding
yeah um and the good of skateboarding
and but oh i'm still to this day i mean
no matter what i'm doing it's like oh my
god
selling out
really absolutely yeah
maybe that's the only thing they have on
you because they can't come for you
right like they can't come like there's
certain dudes like like we always bring
up like david beckham in this like david
beckham was more famous than he was
uh six he was more famous than he was
good at the sport even though he was
amazing at the sport he was like super
high level but they were better guys
than him yeah right
you don't fall in the same category like
you were the best at your thing and you
were famous yeah but i feel like anytime
there's somebody who's really famous but
they're not the best there's this like
hate from the community it's like
someone else should kind of be there
but i don't understand
that that's it well also but but
in my case because i i have such a
i skate this very specific discipline
that is ram birth skating
it's more like
why do people think that guy's the best
because they're looking at like uh
they're looking at some double set
handrail
or
you know or or like most tech flip trick
on the ground they're just like
it's tony hawkins
and they're right
[Applause]
you